[Music]
we didn't provide we don't use cups we
don't use spoons and if we want to
measure something we wait it so this is
this game now for example when you want
to cook pasta for one person for now
where do you cook 100 grams so most
people would wait it or you just hungry
70 grams of pasta we started with the
non vegetarian which but the vegetarians
can learn something useful because you
can post a recipe without the pancetta
is equally tasty prefer okay so what we
will do you will have to chop onions
healthy it depends on your taste people
who are really picky
in the kitchen they will say no they
have to be super super thin but then you
like the texture the onions then you
just leave
little bit more course that's up you
have to leave the onions and then pan
will make you sweat what to sweat you
maybe sweat when you chop something like
on your turn over the garlic and then
you put it in a pan with some olive oil
just a nonsense doesn't sting and then
we can make it cook with the at low
temperature with a very low temperature
until when it becomes nice and soft then
you can add the other ingredients so for
the non vegetarians
we'll start by chopping the onions make
a sweat and then we will add the child
the recipe that we're doing is called
pasta a la medicina
the name derives from the city at the
time a chain of our teacher it's the
town in central Italy individually
knotted Rome for example is in this
region and they say that the recipe was
invented in the city of our teacher
that's why it's called pasta a la
medicina we'll start here vegetarians so
he will also start with a sweat but this
time with garlic
considering that we want to make about
one meter of pasta per type this is too
much it will just make four or five
cloves and again based on your taste you
can either chop it or you can show you
how you can remove the garlic in the
second half
the bacon curl your fingers
so you don't cut yourself
I mean there are those softer at this
point you can
[Music]
it's just a little bit Brown didn't burn
maybe you are cooking for somebody who
is not so eager eating garlic then this
is gamma
[Music]
[Music]
so we're making one with stranger mentor
and the other
this much you can have five so in this
recipe
usually we are going to use it one
should use bucatini typically they're
sort of spaghetti with thicker and they
have is this pasta but it's very
difficult to find in a regular grocery
store in the u.s. so it doesn't really
make sense get something that you will
never find unless you you go to an
Italian store and you can use fettuccine
along you can also use any other kind of
pasta whatever you have
for the example is that each of you
[Music]
before the pasta
[Music]